[Music]
in avocado attack new hmm avocado attack
the Sun is brutal in teens avocados are
9 submitted by you're not my dad
you're numb at that day you don't
[ __ ] know that [ __ ] yeah all the god
of hurling man has been charged with
assaulting a bodega worker ah
is it peeled avocado or in the in the
hold leathery shell and was it right oh
yeah god so hard how do you think
someone with the avocado just check it
out it look like a brick when it's like
oh I was just thinking of smashing them
over the head and I was like it's called
squishy and soft and [ __ ] chucking it
yeah hole all the colors are pretty hard
you could break one another thing they
were a rock-hard avocado so like a stone
he's basically stone broke this dude's
jaw oh I know the really warm ANOVA
decision why would you chuck it in it so
apparently was do named Fred Oh Brad do
out of my country Mexican no is Brad the
victim no so Brad the bad guy right the
guy curling but the reason I'm like oh
oh no my Brad go back oh man how does it
make sense I know I know you're might
people will get out of your Mexican I
think is don't and their kid bread he
doesn't hear buses yes oh yeah what
about a [ __ ] rag oh man
no Brad Gomez 28 years old by the way he
was against some sort of verbal
altercation with one of the bodega
workers
what is that bodega worker like a deli
it's like a deli in a restaurant
screenplay yeah I think that boom today
make like a sandwich Brad is a customer
right he was complaining about there's
two separate reports one of them is the
order was wrong the other one was that
his order was taking too long I don't
know exactly which one it was but point
is start arguing with an employee he got
angry on yeah that's when he started
picking up like four avocados fourth I
was and he holds him here I'm going to
show you guys a video but still want to
walk you through it so in here all of
them just starts chopping at a mirror
and so a mere 21 years old
he doesn't speak English so here just
like what like what's happening right
how can you get in a fight with the
person that you can't even communicate
with no that's kind of sad
yeah the way they're reporting it if you
like Brad was arguing with a separate
employee what'd he do at the wrong
person
faster all the way as it seems like
they're reporting it that's not so wrong
here we go here's the video why their
heads blur uh-oh this is Brad that's
premeditated oh my god he blindsided up
yeah that's [ __ ] up he's getting more
[Music]
over a sandwich yeah see I don't know
exactly why and it's only got it - what
because then there was another report
thing he got angry that Amir didn't
speak English so man I wish I was Amir
and I own that store what is this guy
doing what do you even took off his belt
he looked very low if I owned that
[ __ ] store I would definitely more
guarantee I would have a gun in there
and I would blast the [ __ ] out of the
face tattoo dude you don't know [ __ ] now
blast the [ __ ] out of you what you want
yeah that's so that's terrible ribs
assault with a deadly avocado man it
sucks but I'm kind of glad that it's
just avocados and that's crazy oh oh
straw yeah he got surgery
dude that's [ __ ] crazy my listing
didn't do any why does he look like a
buff cultured thanks he likes my
Dominican huh
he looked amazing fun he does look
Dominican like I don't know for sure he
should be to go I think he should go to
jail for like a few years and I want to
get the [ __ ] you know yeah what happened
to him do you go to uh so he hasn't
arrested so apparently what was reported
was that he hit the police and was like
hey I'll turn myself in Thursday morning
Thursday morning comes around he didn't
turn himself in and the police had to go
out and get him this is Thursday already
oh my god I forgot the [ __ ] cops wait
until first I know that's not
I'm gonna say what have you the fan and
he's all like hold up I'm still watching
some J kake news right now watching our
showed you PETA shoot that's sex man I
feel so bad for that guy yeah this place
anger man I never got so angry at a
place where I wanted to destroy the
place even if I got feel like I got
[ __ ] over we're even hurt somebody
that wasn't involved in the thing
exactly this guy was doing is adding job
he couldn't even speak English he
probably even know what's going on he's
a girl but god I just like things just
fine yeah he was just walking across and
he just got hit in the face yeah he
wasn't even prepared that's [ __ ] up
that's why he should have had a shotgun
I'm telling you straighten once my jaw
is broken you're going to get [ __ ]
shot
like that's it because it wasn't like he
threw a bananas like I've been like I'll
call the cops but he broke his jaw yeah
at that point you got your shot bro and
he grabbed a few yeah yeah bad exactly
his friend was even worse because this
friend wasn't even only part of it it's
not like destroying their head you took
off his belt whipping it around well he
took off his belt just take it off you
didn't hit anybody nobody so funny if he
took it off and it's passed fell down
and he's like walking off with just like
pants or anything did his friend get a
get arrested as well that's the thing
they're saying that's the other man I
can you not arrested I don't know if
they're going to arrest him
I don't know the details of that what a
big sack of [ __ ] Dookie man you look
like a nice place too
it did it did the bananas weren't very
ripe though they're pretty clean line 34
did not even see any bananas I ended up
grabbing the definitive [ __ ] banana
wielding [ __ ] if you guys are our
customers here would you intervene right
yeah would you do Ranger well no I mean
like honestly I would probably get my
butt kicked those guys already could
beat me up but not if you go behind them
and you get like a [ __ ] pickle jar
then you just [ __ ] crack it over the
back of their head he's knocked out for
sure exactly let me kill him I'll go
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't I don't know I
think first I would just like be shocked
but what the [ __ ] is going on I would
tackle him
no talking women I'd get my butt handed
to me but at least by that will first I
commented one
and then I looked smart online one-one
in the NASA word because at least if
he's beating me up he's sticking around
by the time like he's done before you
help the cop forget time you did my job
yeah keep beating me up are you good
oh I'm not also motive to film it for me
no we're happy my job yeah my job would
be handling the just I'm right in the
[ __ ] ball or just even like hold up a
phone and be like hey dude I'm recording
this if you punch me I'm going to sue
you most people won't punch you cuz I
don't wanna get serious like yeah well
here's video proof this is love
streaming oh you don't know he might go
an avocado I'm all with anger problems
though they know that there's cameras
but they just don't give a [ __ ] you
could pull out a phone they're not going
to care so I guess back my first plan
no.1 I think I probably just watch them
because it's not that crazy or someone's
dying yeah but these John ago but you
don't know that jaws broken or anything
like if yours they're like we know the
jobs broken now it's fruits being thrown
yeah but didn't they're you're just like
okay this guy's getting hard rock all
Meccano you don't know whether they're
though you don't mean I don't know
different though that's because you're
your parents don't own a business though
like if I saw that at a small business I
can't watch that because my tanks over
small business or even different people
like you don't know the guys getting
pummeled to death but like whatever you
saw Joe getting pwned by an avocado
would you try to put it my friends
that's different but if I have no ties
with yeah it's kind of you're going to
just sit back and observe and if there's
actually like no fatal threat and the
violence isn't crazy or not like for
example this actually happened to me we
were in Pasadena at this burger place
and she went to go use the bathroom and
I'll just either eating and I'll just
watching like UFC fight and and you know
those people that look like they're in
between being homeless but probably not
homeless but they have too much sweat
loulou's this guy with the skateboard it
looks like he's dressy like pretty
stylish but then you have stains on so
you don't know if you like homeless or
not so he comes in and he goes there you
go eat that is my french fries already
but I don't know I just take it and in
the cook he turns around and he goes hey
don't be bugging my customers don't know
not squeaky wants my leftover fries he
goes nah don't be bugging my customers
maybe they have prior history Nico yeah
and then he each dating goes like a
whatever I want I just sat there and I
just look look
or none and then he told me hey I told
you what I'm gonna tell you one more
time don't bug my customers that guy he
grabbed a handful of fries and threw it
at the chef or at the cook him in the
face and there's ketchup and then stuff
oh [ __ ] this guy he jumps over the
counter and grabbed and this guy was
like the guy that was holding the fries
by like about 50 the the cook looked
like he was like 250 like a Mexican
juggernaut and he jumps over how did he
even jump over the counter he jumped
over grabbed him by the neck and pushed
him - no those barstools that are built
into the ground yeah he pushed him so
hard three of them fell over from all
cause everything was being settled by
itself I have to do anything because
like the violence wasn't high enough
where someone was dying but that's a
different situation where like I think
it's both ways when somewhere with this
the guy if I was in then I see what's
going on the guys walking then he gets
pummeled by avocados if he's crying like
and whimpering I tried step in yeah but
like at that moment I don't really know
like you you don't know how in pain
someone it could just be like boom and
they're just like for me it's not the
person that's in pain they're destroying
the business he was throwing the ticks
down [ __ ] chucking [ __ ] all the other
AAA it's not the fact that he got
avocado so he was destroying he was
trying to destroy the business yeah and
actually my parent that's different yeah
so it's like y'all well like the other
thing you guys have to take into
consideration is are they armed well you
throw the avocado I'm pretty sure he's
not yeah I mean some people might be
[ __ ] nuts and they throw stuff but
they might have a knife in their longing
because there's like it all depends on
how many layers hot pepper spring so you
could just kind of sit back and watch
and there's a I think there's a lot of
different ways to defuse it like if
you're a bystander they're probably not
going to be mad at you they're mad at
the workers right so you can put
yourself in the middle like dude come on
chill but if they're really going to be
crazy to just poke their [ __ ] eyes
out so they can't throw I'm like you're
sitting amongst all that stuff to be
like no joke and he's like ha ha ha
how did enough think of that you just
kind of like you know what you're going
too far
[Laughter]
what's up you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] links in the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]